European Union Finance and economy
ministers will strive this week to forge
a common approach on new rules to
preempt bank crisis the aim is to help a
struggling credit institution or
investment firm to recover from any
shock in an orderly manner preserving
its operations and minimizing the
possibility of taxpayer losses the
proposals concern the single resolution
mechanism and single bank resolution
fund which are a key part of the e use
banking Union they would allow for banks
to be restructured and avoid any shock
liquidation under national insolvency
laws which could harm economic stability
the council will also try to reach a
political agreement on rules governing
savings taxation the proposal would
oblige authorities to exchange
information so that interest payments
made in one nation to people from
another EU state are taxed under the
laws of their country of residence the
goal is to help hide tax evasion The
ministers will also take stock of
efforts to prevent money laundering and
terrorism financing and study a proposal
to simplify value added tax returns
across Europe